[Music]
welcome back to another amazing episode
of off the record with the careful boys
and really excited we got j.r today over
here
what's up jrm hey let us know about you
dude let us know about you uh
i am a comic i'm a that's mad funny
no but you're telling us that you're
telling us you lived in a van for a year
yes yeah that's interesting i did van
life for a year all my friends would be
like oh you're like homeless i was like
no no it's van life it's a thing you
live
the dream bro no i had a good time you
lived judging yes did you have like one
of those hooked up fans i had yeah so it
had a it was a ford transit medium roof
250 and what does that mean what does
all that mean it's a good stack
it's like a white like unmarked van it's
like a cargo van it's a cargo van so
that way you could do like stealth
camping but what's the 250 mean what is
the 250
it's like how much you can capacity of
people yeah how much you can like what's
the word toe how much you can tow oh
okay
i don't really know is it is it is it
was it diesel or was it just it was gas
okay because i don't know a lot about
the diesel engine so if it broke down
like i wanted to be able to like still
do stuff with it all so you can fix your
own stuff and all that nah okay
diesel's actually easier
[Laughter]
you're a gasoline guy no not really no
no but just like mentally for my head
that's why i got ah it made me feel
safer because i have a gas car
if it makes it work if it makes a sound
i don't even know if it comes with
diesel dude honestly i just wanted to be
a car guys they do they do have diesel
yeah
but i uh have like a mattress and a
kitchen like that this is a bed
there was a kit like a stove sink
oh like those things that people don't
do [ __ ] contests on instagram where
you can win like [ __ ] vans like yeah
oh man
yeah dude i hella tried one time i lost
absolutely dude i donated like 200 bucks
to amaze thinking like dude if i do 200
i'll get it but i don't know
when did you buy it and did you buy new
did you like i got it in
2019 and it was a 2015. you were one of
those early adopting van life he was
doing it before it was cool man no
because i just i had the dream since
like high school to do that oh [ __ ]
what made that dream like happen um what
was i doing i think i was just like saw
homeless guy yeah yeah i didn't want
that
so almost you're just so free yeah dude
i want to smell like that guy
i'm confined to this awesome house i
know i have this apartment where i can
walk around
too much
no i think i just i was like touring a
bunch and i would go to a city and
always wonder would be like to like
explore it for longer
but i couldn't because i'd have to fly
out the next day
so for this i would go to a city do the
show go to a national park nearby like
go for like a week and then and then
drive to the next show so did you just
[ __ ] in the woods no i have yeah that's
pretty dope huh
i do have [ __ ] in joshua tree
[ __ ] in the grand canyon really [ __ ] not
america dude
everywhere man that's the name of your
tour right
do you have a
shower in there or you gotta like go to
like a koat campsite i would shower at
like planet fitness or a lot of times
like i mean it's pretty isolated it's
just you in the van yeah so i would plan
stops at like friends places in like
different cities so i saw my cousin in
vegas um
saw people here in l.a for a little bit
stuff like that and which shower at
their places or a gym so you just have a
stove and a mattress
is there there's no toilet in there
there's no toilet in there so i would
pee in a bunch of bottles dude cool man
are you pretty good your technique
pretty good uh i'm not up there fill
this up right now let's go dude
on camera i like a wide mouth
get your little [ __ ] out of here yeah
that's for me it only yeah you take this
one
funnel for that or just straight up do
they have that though for girls pee
funnels
it's called the it's called the she-wee
oh yeah
it's like a little hammock you attach to
your it's like it's like it's like a
little funnel thing so they could pee
into like a bottle or something so i did
i did a van life for a little over a
week and then the the hardest thing for
me was
figuring out where i can park over the
night except i mean all walmart's week
yeah
but like when it came to like different
states have different rules for like
campsites and like forests and whatever
right so some of the places we did was
straight gorilla i don't know if we're
allowed to yeah same yeah and then um
the other thing was timing my bathroom
stuff because like when you live in a
house you just go i gotta go right but
then like if you got a [ __ ] in the
middle of the night kind of sucks it's
cold or whatever
um i would plan my shits first yeah you
got to plan all that so so how how did
you get used to uh
did you plan ahead like oh i could camp
here tonight or like yeah so i like
there's a app it's called i overlander
and it would show where other people
have parked and like review it like yelp
reviews of like like no cops come here
yeah no serial killers yeah exactly like
there was like oh it's kind of loud or
like it's creepy or whatever i parked
one time on the one here in la like near
like santa monica yeah pch yeah thinking
like oh this is gonna be the dream but
actually it's it sucks because like car
cars are going by all night couldn't
sleep my van's like shaking and [ __ ]
like
yeah so that one sucks but that is it by
more like the malibu side where there's
hella people parked there like surfers
and stuff like i see a lot of van life
people there are a bunch of vans out
there like schoolies like buses and all
that stuff but and you i've parked in a
few neighborhoods but you're not
supposed to because then it kind of put
like makes van life people look bad
because we're like staying in
your neighborhood creeping out families
you're like wait so you are living in
advance and you live back in the
neighborhood yeah yeah exactly but it
was cool because it was a way for me to
see la like i stayed in uh
i parked in marina del rey one time and
i was like dude i live in marina del rey
yeah
any like scary moments while you were
van lifeing it was weird because like
the same reason i got into it was also
kind of creepy like
i went i went to the i went to the grand
canyon i was like by myself and i'm
looking out the window dude i'm like
completely alone this is beautiful i was
like dude but if i died here tonight
like it would just be me yeah yeah and
it would be beautiful it would be so
beautiful yeah privacy and death dude i
i was high as [ __ ] sleeping in the
hammock right in the forest and i was
like
anybody could come with a spear right
now and stab the [ __ ] out of me but
still the spears happened in this forest
yeah they could javelin thrust me right
now i and a spear will just come at you
in the morning i don't even know they're
coming i'm like i have a gun in my
pocket and i'm like
it does nothing to it you gotta sleep
with the frying pan on your chest
[Laughter]
full armor medieval armor thing i saw
you coming [ __ ] that's why i got
this so any uh
any uh
you know oh man
okay so actually when i started this
thing turn it into a shag wagon
see if the suspension works i did like a
year um of like abstinence i didn't have
sex for like a year what made you do
that i broke that abstinence in that
band
was why why did you make that choice
and does this jacking off count yeah i
didn't i didn't i didn't i didn't do
that
no sex yeah well i mean what got you to
do that because to me they're actually
glory at the end
[Laughter]
no that's just i can't even consider
that that's suicide if someone said you
got you you you'd rather [ __ ] fast or
get some [ __ ] i'd be like i'll i won't
eat it are you just angry all the time i
feel like you
didn't even jack off no no no why why
did you why did you get like i did
through like i jumped down just so
strong i could like read people's minds
but only if they oh only if they were
jerking off oh man yeah i was like
no like i i wanted to like reset like my
mind and stuff because i felt like
i don't know i just needed like you know
growing up like watching like porn and
all this stuff i felt like my brain was
just super
like different you jacked off too much
jacked off too much dude jack my life
away
that's a lot of discipline though yeah
for a whole year dude your sperm were
crowded bro
yeah what the second i first noted they
were like hey excuse me excuse me
[Laughter]
what was that first one like when you
came back too you know it was passed out
because it was full on sex that it
wasn't like jacking off after a year i
was like the whole thing was it
different damn it was like i don't know
it was cool it was cool yeah it was like
a rece it was like was it worth it was
it worth the year of not doing it it was
it was yeah
you were surprised what made what made
it worthwhile what made it work was like
kiss busting out and be like all right
let's reset
that's your boy right here what made it
worthwhile was like i did feel like kind
of different i felt like a little more
like intentional about stuff versus
before it might just be like uh like
compulsive or something for me and then
so in this what does that mean it's so
vague
i don't know i'm trying to be
intentional what do you mean by
intentionally before maybe before you
when you have it all the time you're
just trying to bust at the end of the
day yeah but maybe when you have a bus
in hell long you're like i need to make
this last or something i don't know like
i'm like saving my bus you know it's
like okay this is like a good buck
because it's a little tally
instead of like busting to like sneeze
or something you know you gotta edge bro
take that [ __ ] out and need her out
i don't know what any of that just take
this [ __ ] out eat her out baby that's
that's a shirt too black comic dude this
has a black comic
that's crazy
words of wisdom the whole year of
nothing happened to java did you was
your dick ever in pain
the r version yeah sometimes my
different no wet dreams right not
necessarily did you have any wet dreams
the whole year i don't think i did
that's the name so
yeah
i don't think i did are you are you uh
would you consider yourself an introvert
um i feel like i like recharge by myself
like that's introverted yeah yeah yeah
yeah so then like doing the van life
thing you would be there for for days
alone
and then you didn't feel like sad you
just felt fine because people weren't
dealing with [ __ ] people yeah yeah
uh you know i think there were times
that were like harder but it was like
there was one time i went to like st
george utah
and i would go to this like yoga studio
like oh that's dangerous how do you not
jack off after going to a yoga studio
bro like the [ __ ]
dude you
you haven't had sex yeah even dudes
busts look different yep it's man it's
all morning it's all morning there's a
tempting time everyone just jacks off at
the end of yoga right
i would be in the front or else the back
game over i can't [ __ ] connect my
chakras right dude
my chalk was all centered toward my
[ __ ] growing area dude
that i feel like there's a lot of people
that uh have like whether it's like a
one percent fantasy or or as much as
like a 80 dream of like wanting to
experience something like a van life
yeah um who do you feel like you would
either suggest that to you like what
type of person or like what is like the
greatest thing you received from that
experience
um first off he ain't asking no [ __ ]
because they're just too [ __ ]
just kidding
i didn't mean women i'm saying like yeah
like
dudes are like yeah yeah yeah you're too
risky
yeah yeah too [ __ ] too [ __ ] like i
would i think i'd never knew if i could
i've always done crazy [ __ ] like that
i'll like have a regular life for like
two years and then i like traveled to
asia and europe like working odd jobs i
was like teaching english to russian
students like in amsterdam and stuff
like that
just random just random like crazy [ __ ]
and then so but this one i didn't know
if i could actually pull it off like
live in a van for a year so it was like
something that
i think for myself i always wanted to do
prove to yourself you could do it yeah
exactly and spend that much alone time
too yeah and that much time alone not
jerking off too yeah that's pretty crazy
you did a bad life journey but you
dedicated monk life journey yeah you're
like no jackery nothing it was kind of
like my reasoning
as like a rehab
how about the phone and all that stuff
too uh no i had the phone and everything
still too did you feel like you needed
to rehab from well you know actually at
that time like i didn't drink for that
time either so i didn't drink i didn't
like do anything so did you read a lot
of books uh i didn't even know
i wrote a lot of soul cleansing oh you
because you were using all these things
in a way to escape
like you were using pleasure and
dopamine like whatever to yeah yeah that
makes sense it's like if i feel like if
i can really attend it's almost like
what's his name david chowi oh david
yeah that kind of [ __ ] it's like doing
that but in the van just like who am i
type of thing that's tight man i think
um a lot of people just dream of like oh
i want to study abroad and they'll be
like that's cool but then you got like a
bucket list of like five people's
[ __ ] life dreams that you've done man
that's sick yeah yeah i got a bunch of
drinks not busting out for a year
possible
i did it on one unwillingly
unwillingly what way because nobody
wanted to [ __ ] me dude that's why
and i got sad and i didn't jack off and
let me let me tell you this dude it's
not the same experience when it when
it's not unwillingly your body shuts
down to the possibility of sex when you
come back to it your limp as [ __ ] i
never had ed problems in my life dude i
used porn to rehabilitate myself yeah
yeah that's crazy
so all the no fat people that's not the
truth man
i had the opposite experience i came
back to [ __ ] sex and i'm like
what happened
it's not working
but then thank god you know i i had a
lot of good nurses to help me through
holy [ __ ]
peter sinai thank you
shout out shout out
is there something that you think is
like after doing it for a year you're
like there's a big
what did you not expect that happened
during the van life uh what i didn't
expect like passing it on to someone
else where they're like oh this is
probably a common misconception it's not
like the instagram thing where it's
always like beautiful you open the van
door and it's like there's a beach or
like a mountain there's usually a
homeless man saying
the first few months i had to stay in la
of it like i thought i'm gonna go i
wanted to go to florida and back
but for the first few months i was like
sleeping in a park like in l.a i got
parked there because i knew there was
overnight and i would wake up to like
like instead of waking up to birds and
all this stuff it was like two
crackheads arguing in the morning
dude like that's what i wake up to like
oh [ __ ]
i want to like make an instagram video
of me like coming out and waking up to
that yeah instead of like just like van
life reality yeah it'll be a sick ass
show yeah yeah that's what i'm always
curious about because i know la right
and then we have these like van life
influencer girls who have the prettiest
cutest little vans and then they go to
all these different places and i'm like
you don't really van life i don't think
so
because
the the picture that you're painting is
not reality or they only show those
parts of it true but yeah but you know
the other cool thing was everybody wants
to ask you about it and you meet other
van lifers and everyone has a cool story
because no one did like van life just
one day like okay i'm just gonna do it i
met this family it was like
a family of five or something and they
were traveling around with like a
trailer hitch to their truck oh sick and
doing like homeschooling and stuff like
that wow wow
i forget why they got into it but
yeah i
thought it misheard you
i get why they got into it but it was
like it was uh it was cool so they were
very intentional about it and stuff too
should we make a jk van that would be
cool let's throw that in there dude i
saw the kids he has a pretty good a-team
bam oh man you think that'll fit in
there yeah it would actually get a big
enough band yeah no there's no way it
has a [ __ ] 18 band dude
you're either gonna freeze or or roast
like depending on there's no insulation
at all yeah insulation's like the first
thing you need we need a jk
or the cameraman
yeah the driver is always the dude
cracking the jokes in the front while
they're [ __ ]
no girls allowed though yeah yeah yeah
we're just picking up other homies dude
no girls jk baby bus
hey boy you want to make 15 bucks
it's always a hella cheap whatever
like nah i'm good
let's get a short bus
and call it
special school
we're special boys yeah we're special
everyone here is very special
where are we driving to
each other just like no jacking off
either
oh man no only jacking up yeah
for a whole year
yeah for a holy jacket only checking out
for a whole year every time you get in
you gotta check off you can you can't
even drive the van you just gotta jack
off instantly when you get in
where would we go first definitely not
vague is that please suck
we're gonna melt if we go san diego san
diego sounds great yeah and we could
park san diego is like one of the van
life capitals man really
it's beautiful so beautiful i would say
san diego has the best weather in
california we should get the biggest
vehicle and try to go into the smallest
streets
isn't that your whole life
is that just barkquand.com what is that
no dude try to cause a ruckus go on the
bridge when it's like rush hour so we
can be stressed out
we're not even no we're not even going
on going to work so we don't have a rush
but everyone has traditional asian music
from our cultures yeah just be in the
way yeah you know what i like vietnamese
cha-cha music we played it all
throughout our colorado van life trip
because we yeah because we were at a
fuzz restaurant and then like the uncles
in the back were karaoke like and just
having a blast and i'm like damn that's
some dope ass beat and i looked for it
and then i'll [ __ ] show you dude i'll
play that [ __ ] right now man cha-cha
yeah you're going to be cha-cha they got
vietnamese
[ __ ] cha-cha
why is it spaced out like that
i don't know man like
they have an hour-long playlist
[Music]
this is chat i'm not sure this is chad
it's
[Music]
i understand what you mean because
they'd be doing like two step cha cha's
to it yeah
yeah that's pretty cool and specifically
the two-step cha-cha not the triple step
so that's all the elements van
vietncha non-stop jacking it yeah pay
the fare that's what we call it yeah
that sounds like walking animal base
no girls
no girls no diversity either yeah only
yellow faces only yellow face that's it
and we'll call it the
yellow scubas
i'm not sure if i'm sold 100 all right
what do you want then we'll take the bus
to cedar sinai find some nurses what
does it take for you to do my best
monster truck wheels food okay
yeah yeah
[Music]
you